Speaker 1: Let's get into the Friday mailbag.
Info at David Pakman dot com must be spelled
correctly. Not the info. Well, actually it all has
to be spelled correctly, but the info part is the
easy part. It's my last name that often trips
people up. You can send questions, comments,
criticisms, praise. Try to keep the trolling to
a minimum, even though there is always a little
bit. And maybe that's where we will start
today. First message is your Y0. You are an
F with Pacman and they say the full thing with
the F. You must support the loony left. Peatos
and Peatos also with an apostrophe. It's all
weird and it does contain the required your.
You are confusion almost exclusively, almost
unanimously in the hate mail that I receive
and also not a particularly substantive criticism.
And this entire thing with left wing pedophilia.
Not only is it like a strange obsession for many
on the right. It really actually seems like it's
the right that has a problem with this issue. But
let's not make it political. Let's just leave it
at that. Another message. Not pleased with my
commentary. I watched your insulting Herschel
Walker video. And I got to say, as someone who
had worked with the developmentally disabled and
mentally ill. You should be ashamed. I reported
your garbage commentary to Facebook. You do
realize people with brain injuries can work. Also
wondering if Walker was a Democrat, would you have
still said everything you did? Yes, guys. First
of all, this person seems to be saying Herschel
Walker is developmentally disabled or mentally ill
or has a brain injury, which the right denies. And
now this person is saying, not only is it true,
you're bad for bringing it up, David, I was not
making fun of anything. I was not saying anything
other than this guy cannot speak. He cannot form
a coherent sentence. He should obviously not be a
valid candidate to be one of 100 senators in the
United States. Whatever issues he's dealing
with, if it's mental illness, he should get
treatment. If it's a brain injury, he should get
treatment. If it's a developmental disability.
Full dignity and respect to all of it. And his
inability to express himself about even one issue
that is important to him should make it so that no
voter would say, this is the guy that needs to be
a senator. That's the point. And that's as far
as it goes. Next, the email is from Sarah. Now,
I'm going to have to keep doing this in order for
people to understand what's going on. Sarah wrote
to me and said, Possible scam in your name, David.
I subscribe to the David Pakman show on YouTube.
Recently, David included a photo of himself with
his child, to which I commented Congratulations.
Upon seeing notifications later, I noticed
there was a response supposedly by David,
but which immediately raised my hackles as a scam.
I've copied the text to include with this email,
and it's someone that looks like me telling Sarah
to DM them on WhatsApp. I want to make we're we
are playing Whac-A-Mole with these spammers.
Okay. I am not trying to contact any of you by
WhatsApp or text message. I love all the fans,
all the viewers, the audience love all of you.
I'm not trying to text you. I'm not trying to
WhatsApp you. I am too busy and there are dozens
of accounts using my face, if you can imagine a
face like this. It's being used to scam people
into like eventually it will be about you. They'll
invest your money for you or they need, you know,
whatever. It's some financial scam. So if you
see any account that claims to be me trying to
get you to contact them or saying I want to text
you or whatever, report it for impersonation,
it is not me. I can talk to you if you call in.
Okay. When we take live calls. I am not trying
to text anybody. Love everybody with peace
and love. I'm not trying to WhatsApp you.
I'm not trying to text you. All right. Sarah Metz
wrote in about monkeypox. And one of the things I
really don't like is when people criticize me
for things I didn't say. I say plenty on the
show worthy of criticism. Criticize me for that,
not for things I didn't say. Mathias says. Sir,
yesterday you mentioned it was homophobic to bring
up the fact that the vast majority of monkeypox
cases are men who have sex with men. Isn't it a
disservice to be dishonest with the gay community?
I did not say that it is homophobic to bring up
the fact that the majority of cases early on were
men who have sex with men. What I said was that
it was homophobic not to care about monkeypox
because you believe it is only affecting gay men,
which is what Marjorie Taylor GREENE was saying.
Keep in mind, this poor communicator that people
thought I was being homophobic or sorry that I
was saying it was homophobic merely to point out
a statistic. No, that is not what I said. What I
said was there are people on the right laughing
this off like they laughed off AIDS for a while
by saying, I don't care about this.
It's only affecting gay men. And it
is not only affecting gay men. I just
actually got a message from a woman
who has monkeypox, and I guess now she's over
it. Actually, she caught it two months ago.
Come on, guys. Come on. That criticize me for
the things that I'm saying. Seema wrote to me
about live golf. And says, I have little
confidence you'll pay attention to this,
but I'm giving it a shot. I saw your comments
about the live golf tournament. Please. It is not
live golf. It's 54 golf. I expected much more of
you. A cultured celebrity live is a Roman number
54 alive. Placing it in the name of the tournament
refers to the number of hits a player would need
to make if all the holes were par or something
like that. Please. 50 for golf. Not live golf.
I have not heard a single news report. Sports
channel, golfer or athlete. Call it 54. Golf.
Okay. Everyone's calling it live golf. I get it.
I understand Roman numerals, but I've not heard it
called 54 golf even once. So it seems it would
be weird if all of a sudden I start calling it
54 golf. I don't think anyone would have any
idea what I'm talking about. All right, CMA.
So I want to be understood. That's the
priority. Chris wrote in about electric cars,
a topic near and dear to my heart. Chris. David,
thank you for addressing the issue of right wing
disgust against electric cars and similarly any
type of green tech. I've been driving an electric
car for almost five years. I've experienced
everything that you have, and I agree with
everything that you said in this segment. If there
was ever a litmus test of right wing intelligence
or lack thereof, the reaction to electric cars is
that, yeah, they really don't understand anything.
Another one that I'm hearing is that they're
saying, you know, electric cars, you need metal,
you need tires in it. Right. But you need those
things with internal combustion engines as well.
But at least you're not burning fossil fuels when
you drive around. I get it. There's still a carbon
footprint to an electric car. Nobody's denying
that, but they seem increasingly desperate.
Ignorant and unhinged in the criticism of electric
vehicles. And by the way, no one's forcing you to
go and get an electric vehicle. If you're happy
with paying for gas and, you know, the noise of
internal combustion engines and all the moving
parts that can break. Stick with it. No, nobody's
forcing you to get on an electric vehicle. It's
just as the technology matures and the charging
network expands and the vehicles improve and get
cheaper and cheaper. Those internal combustion
engines are looking pretty antiquated. I think
that's the main point. Jason wrote in about fuel
prices and has another interesting take on the
electric vehicle discussion. Jason says, I don't
own an electric vehicle currently and don't
benefit from high prices. So high prices are a
net negative for me financially. However, based on
the need to reduce our dependance on fossil fuels,
I'm actually to the point where I don't want
fuel prices to come down. While I don't want
to see the oil corporations benefit, I also think
big picture, we need to reduce demand and use it
in some way. Tactically, I don't know what it
looks like. Do you think there's any chance the
masses will understand how the need to prioritize
the existence of our species? Our planet has to
come before any economic interest. Yeah, I've
mentioned this before in a different context,
which is super high gas prices aren't necessarily
the best for oil companies and gas stations long
term because they reduce demand. And this is sort
of what the point Jason is making. If gas prices
are cartoonishly high, it makes electric vehicles
comparatively less expensive because it increases
the cost of ownership of a of a and a gas
powered vehicle. And Jason is absolutely correct.
Absolutely correct. Brian wrote in about
3D printed guns. You might remember that
a homemade gun was used in the assassination of
the former Japanese prime minister Shinzo Abe.
And Brian says, If we can digitally keep
photocopiers from duplicating currency,
why couldn't we use the same concept to keep
3D printers from producing gun parts, make it
recognize a part in any plane and have updates.
Just thinking keep up the great work. Yeah,
this is an important thing. We have seen a lot
of people on the right when presented with the
obvious need for gun safety regulations. They
go, Hey, listen, even if you get rid of guns,
the guy in Japan printed his gun at home or
made his gun at home. So getting rid of guns
won't solve anything. Well, it would in the sense
that most people aren't going to be able to make
a gun at home. And the ones that are able to do
it aren't necessarily going to do it because it's
more work and people are fundamentally lazy. So
obviously, will some people figure out a way to
print guns at home? If you ban the ability to buy
a certain gun on the open market. Yeah, but most
of them are not. And then you get to the next
question, which is just because you could print
a gun at home, even though most people won't. You
can also regulate 3D printers in some way. And I
know that you could make the case, well, you can
slice and dice the parts thinner and thinner to
where they wouldn't be recognized as gun parts.
Okay, I get it. But the point is, you also can
make it more difficult to print a 3D gun at home
for those that have a 3D printer. It's weird
how they act like we have no agency or ability to
control technology whatsoever. Everybody will just
print guns at home, will they? Well, most people
don't have printers, and even if they did, you can
also limit some of the parts that can be printed.
They just throw in the towel like we have no more
power. The email is absolutely correct. Send me
your thoughts. Questions, comments, concerns.
Demands for an apology. Hopefully a legitimate
demand to info at David Pakman dot com. And
the party doesn't have to stop now. We do
have the bonus show every single weekday.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else
that makes money to fund themselves.
Speaker 1: You can sign up at join
Packman dot com you can use the coupon code
big voting 20 to get the bonus show. Folks
if Alex Jones doesn't like it, it should at least
pique your interest a little bit. See you there.